all right so i got curious about
something i saw this so there's this guy
named mark manson mark manson has this
book called the subtle art of not giving
a then he created a couple
spin-offs from it so i'll tell you a
quick a funny story so this book uh was
the best-selling book of 2020 i believe
or 19 either 19 or 20. i forget the
exact year
um and it or maybe even prior before
that actually but it just sold like many
many millions copies of books i actually
had uh dinner at a conference with
tucker who we were just talking about
and mark manson sat next to me and i was
talking to him and i was like so what do
your parents think about your job and he
goes well they kind of make fun of me
and ask when i'm going to get a real job
they don't really know what i do they
just think i play in the computer all
day and i play video games all day they
don't truly understand like what i'm
doing but they kind of understood it
this year when they released a report
for new york times saying i sold more
books than hillary clinton so that's
when they that's when they kind of
understood what i do and so uh that's a
funny story about mark but i looked up
uh i was i was curious about something
about him and i googled and the first
article came out that he had a condo in
new york city that he recently sold for
14 million dollars and i got curious
about that because i think that book i
was like books can't make that much
money can they and atomic habits this
year sold or so far has sold around five
million books in total and this year
atomic habits was the best-selling book
on amazon in 2020 um or 2021 and i was
curious about how much
bookmakers uh
authors make so i i have a friend i
can't talk about his name but he sold 30
000 copies of a book that was published
on a major publisher and i want to
explain to you how much money he made by
the way and that 30 000 that's a ton
that's like in the top one percentile
you know yes this book is in bookstores
and it's probably in the airport and
things like that
so they were given they didn't have a
book before they were given a 250 000
advance which is basically just like uh
here's 250 go
yeah and go write the book
um
off that 30 000 in books
they have not made a cent in royalty or
licensing fees and he told me that when
he was looking at the contract he
doesn't even entirely understand when
he's gonna get paid
past that amount and he only gets paid
like pennies on the dollar for every
like fourteen dollar book sold right and
he said he's like i he goes basically i
get paid they spent a certain amount of
money to help me make this book and they
get paid once it's i get paid once it
surpasses that amount but i can't even
understand in the paperwork how much
they spent like including everyone's
salaries on doing this and publishing
and things like that but i have made he
said an additional four hundred thousand
dollars this year on selling other stuff
like courses and coaching and consulting
which wouldn't have happened because uh
which happened because of the book but
basically on 30 000
copies sold he has not made a cent other
than the 250 and he told me that his
editor wasn't that good that he had to
spend a little bit of money uh
get
getting their his own editor and that
their marketing people weren't that
great and i found it to be very
interesting and so i looked up dan
blizzarian dan bilzerian you know who he
is the instagram guy he self-published
his book and so dan bazarian's book it
costs 35 and he has a shopify store that
sells it you can't buy it on amazon
and it works for dan blizzarian because
he just posts a link on instagram and he
goes viral but david goggins did it as
well
and so anyway this whole publishing kind
of thing got me interested because these
people do not i guess mark manson he
must have crushed it somehow but for
someone who sells 30 000 books they
don't make off their off their
books and i found it to be incredibly
fascinating i guess if you're like ryan
holiday i heard that he makes he does
good but a lot of people they just don't
get paid well i think it's two things
it's if you take an advance
the econo and it's your first book the
economics can be super skewed against
you
if you um if you have multiple hits like
a ryan holiday then you know by the time
you negotiate your third book deal
you're gonna have much better economics
in the thing you know tim ferriss
probably made more of his last book than
he did off the first book which is the
best seller
um
and then the last thing is
self-publishing you know changing the
game in a way so you know let's say a
book sells for 13.99 or whatever 14
bucks
um you know i think it's gonna be like
probably uh
you know seven eight bucks of just the
cost of the book plus shipping to get it
to a customer and you know so you're
left with four or five bucks
at the end
to play with now whether that goes all
in your pocket or your publisher's
pocket i think that depends on how you
negotiate but even if you just take four
bucks per copy um you know five million
copies sold for atomic habits you know i
would believe that he's grossed you know
20 million 30 million in sales uh i'm
sorry like gross profit off that now i
don't know what his deal was if he's i
don't know if he's self-published or
what well five million books times
fourteen dollars is seventy thousand
seventy million so the the revenue on
that i would bet is in the 50 to 100
million range yeah that huge ballpark
but i don't know what a guy like him
would make but i bet you he could get
paid like
many thousands an hour to come and talk
i mean i bet you even cost him fifty
thousand dollars to show up at a at a
board room in new york to give a
discussion to get yeah i just got paid
eight thousand dollars to do a zoom call
for one hour um really to give a talk
and so that means that somebody who's
you know the author of atomic habits is
definitely commanding you know 25 50k
per person that's crazy
that's crazy so anyway i thought uh i
thought this was interesting and uh
it shocked me
writing a book because you're going
through this i know i know you're
thinking about going through i don't
know how far how far you are i basically
paid to write the book and now i gotta
write the book this year so that'll
happen
uh and so
yeah i don't i would predict that you
don't make money directly off of it but
i imagine there will be money made in
some ways yeah i think a book is a
pretty horrible way to make money so i'm
just doing it for fun
[Music]
you